we got to talk about this triple evasion
it is this how you saw it going down but
did you expect when it came up I mean
yeah we kind of knew the entire there
probably was a triple just based on the
numbers we knew that we were sort of on
the outs of some of the groups inside of
there so was it expected probably yeah
still kind of disappointing absolutely
yeah I was gonna make it through by
myself probably without a lien without
Johnny or I was gonna be out with one of
them right I did hope though that in
making the deal with will not in Paris
the prior week they would have kept me
safe and even when I was been evicted
Paris was saying as much but like I mean
they all stopped me such a threat in
there so yeah is there any like residual
emotional feeling about that or you just
know that's just the way it goes because
you would have done the same thing to
other people I'm a little irritated
currently still I'll get over it but I
know that's just a game like they're
just doing what's best for their game
and I definitely respect that but it's
hard when you feel like you had
something with someone and then you just
blindsided two seconds before the live
eviction
yeah and frustrating with the group
that's left in there even at the
beginning of the season I thought it
would be totally different
and those five like respect to them of
course but there's so many people I'd
rather see within the game right some of
those five so now Johnny you were very
vocal not secretive at all about wanting
to blow up and like you know it was a
strategy or emotion the fact that you
were know out there with it yeah I mean
it got to the point where they
absolutely knew I was coming for them I
knew they were coming for me there was
no reason to kind of like play the game
of weird with each other we appreciate
you work in the future and I thought to
myself like every single person this
house doesn't want to take me dancing
they think I'm gonna win against them so
going against Derek and Kayla that hard
would kind of put it in people's minds
that potentially they wouldn't vote from
the end so I thought that could also
work my favorite should I survive the
triple and given who's left over three
the people have never really know
anything what are their chances you
think not good in my opinion out there
very good unless one of them manages to
pull it off but the thing is is Maddy is
really good with mental but not so
physical endurance yeah true it's
following week if that's what the comp
is we don't know maybe will will it said
this entire time like I'm not fluid I'm
not she looked angry good stuff
so we'll see well what are you like what
are your predictions for this looking
forward I think Kayla might win yeah I
think in my honesty final three if it's
like Maddie
and then Dayla I think Kayla will choose
Maddie over Derek just to get just keep
saying that she wants to cut her show
man the game I'm turning on my alleys
I'm gonna go with dealer now yeah now
that you've had a sleepless night to
think it over
right are there any game moves that you
would have done differently I think you
would do over I don't have any regrets
really because in the moment with the
mountain the knowledge that I had it
seemed like the right thing to do but if
I could do something differently I would
choose not evict Erica yeah I would also
make Liv not evict erica things but also
even though I thought a lien lived
definitely would have voted out one of
will man in Paris had even come up
beside kill this week she's saying to me
now that that wouldn't be the case so
maybe if I threw Maddie up there Maddie
could've yeah I gave him my word and he
liked to have him inside there for the
triple would have maybe bettered my odds
but that's me in a valley what do you
think her reactions are gonna be when
she sees you guys like she's gonna be so
happy and immediately the upside open
just like share everything it's gonna be
like a good time yeah it's gonna go you
are you looking forward to the next step
now you know yeah we're gonna have fun I
think that for the most part we're all
pretty open to our votes the end like if
people can come in there with passion
conviction tell us why they deserve the
game maybe they'll get it mm-hmm they
have to have proof though I don't want
none of that
yes I was going off yeah yeah I don't
hear that either you weren't you weren't
at all there's no person there play
cutthroat and they're gonna try to sell
us on like honesty truth love you like
I'm just just be straight up about it we
got you we did this once you know I want
the dirt you know yeah get messy